- [Instructor] We're told
that Nierria earns $75
for 4 hours of tutoring.
How much does Nierria earn
for 1 hour of tutoring?
Pause this video, and see
if you can figure that out.
Well, the key here is $75
for 4 hours of tutoring.
And there's a couple of
ways you can think about it.
The ratio here is $75 for every 4 hours.
So if you wanted one hour of tutoring,
well, it's just going
to be 1/4 of the $75,
or you could just take 75 and divide by 4.
Another way you could think about it,
you could say Nierria gets $75
for every 4 hours,
which is another way of saying
that Nierria is going to earn
75 divided by 4 dollars per hour.
So really we just have to figure out
what 75 divided by 4 is.
So let's do a little bit of long division.
So 4 goes into 7 one time, 1 times 4 is 4.
We're going to subtract. 7 minus 4 is 3.
Bring down that 5.
4 goes into 35 eight times.
8 times 4 is 32.
I will subtract again. I get a 3.
Well now I'm going to
get some decimals here,
so let me bring down a zero.
4 goes into 30 seven times.
7 times 4 is 28.
Subtract, and then I get a
2. Bring down another zero.
4 goes into 20 five times.
5 times 4 is 20, and I am done,
no more remainder here.
So we get that Nierria
earns 18.75 dollars,
dollars per hour,
or you can just say that
she makes $18.75 per hour.